no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español hoy ponemos la mirage en
argentina el país sudamericano que pese
a las promesas de gobiernos sucesivos
vuelve a encontrarse enfrentado a la
crisis de su deuda y eso en medio de las
consecuencias de la pandemia del
coronavirus para hablar de ello
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio hace
directo ignacio poli economista
consultor independiente quien fuera
entre el 2018 y el 2020 director
ejecutivo por argentina y haití del
banco interamericano de desarrrollo
federico bienvenido a esta escala en
parís
muchas gracias brown federico antes de
comenzar y abordar el tema que nos ocupa
el de la deuda argentina quisiera hacer
una pregunta tiene que ver con el
problema de la carne recientemente el
gobierno del presidente fernández
decidió suspender las exportaciones de
carne argentina por 30 días los
productores de carne han respondido una
huelga de nueve días cómo se explica
esta situación sabiendo que es una
fuente de divisas pero que al mismo
tiempo hay una fuerte inflación del
precio de la carne interna
indudablemente considero que es una mala
medida para atacar el precio de parar el
precio de la carne porque se pierde en
mercados de exportación porque genera
mucha incertidumbre esto es muy
importante una medida así tomada de la
noche a la mañana genera mucho
incertidumbre ya no solo en el sector
sino en el conjunto del sector
empresario aquellos que planifican hacer
una inversión dicen que es lo que pasa
acá que hay un cambio tan brusco en las
reglas de juego
y no es una buena no es una buena medida
no no no va a ayudar los especialistas
dicen que no va a ayudar para bajar de
precio la carne ya en el pasado se hizo
en el 2006 y no sirvió y en este caso
creo que tampoco va a servir para esto y
ya te digo afecta el clima de negocios y
las reglas de juego para la inversión de
manera muy muy fuerte hay que decir que
argentina es el cuarto productor mundial
de carne con fuertes exportaciones en
europa y sobre todo en china el año
pasado fueron más de tres mil millones
de dólares los que recibió por este
concepto pero al mismo tiempo bueno el
hecho es que los precios internos
subieron 65 por ciento en pocos meses
si hay hay pero pero no sólo el precio
de la carne vio en la inflación vamos a
hablar de ello claro
hay una alta inflación de muchos otros
sectores que selló en textiles en
calzado en hay hay muchos sectores que
aumentaron tanto como como la carne
ahora bien no lo que sí quisiera agregar
es que la cuota hilton que es la que
viene a europa i
los países desarrollados quedo afuera de
esta de esta medida y eso es también
importante es decir que no se corta la
exportación de cuota hilton a europa y
esperemos que estos 30 días no se
renueven más en todo caso vamos a
abordar ahora el tema que nos es el
objeto de esta entrevista argentina se
encuentra en recesión
federico y eso desde hace tres años y
además con una situación de un
sobreendeudamiento considerable
actualmente el gobierno tiene que
liquidar una serie de préstamos al fondo
monetario internacional que los próximos
tres años tendrá que desembolsar capital
intereses más de 100 mil millones de
dólares como es posible que argentina
vuelva a encontrarse en una situación
toda proporción guardada claro está y lo
que sucedió entre el 2000 2002 acá
pareciera que cada vez se vuelve al
mismo punto de partida un
sobreendeudamiento del país si mira el
la deuda es el hijo y la madre es el
déficit fiscal cierto entonces lo que
hay que ver es cuál fue el
comportamiento de las cuentas públicas
cuál viene siendo el comportamiento las
cuentas públicas y la verdad que ahí te
encuentras con que el gasto público en
la argentina y la presión impositiva
sobre el sector empresario
son sostenibles y no de este gobierno
obviamente que lleva dos años sino todo
esto te diría que empieza en el en el
gobierno de cristina kirchner que acá
hay hay un aumento del gasto público
espectacular mira cuando tú tomas el
promedio del gasto público consolidado
entre los 60 y el 2000 era de 25 por
ciento y con miras 2015
41 por ciento es decir que se pegó un
incremento de 15 puntos del producto en
en 10 años en 15 años
pero pero más que nada ese aumento fue
entre 2000 fueron fueron en 78 años y lo
otro que ves es la presión impositiva la
presión impositiva está en paso del 20%
en principio de los 2000 a 34 por ciento
ahora que le quitas la informalidad es
decir lo ve sobre la economía formal es
del 43% la argentina es uno de los
países que mayor presión impositiva
tiene en un país subdesarrollado con un
proceso de inversión y enflaquecido y va
muy debilitados y es digo este este esta
es la causa de por qué periódicamente
nos endeudamos y tenemos son
endeudamientos que no podemos afrontar
esa es una parte de la es una parte de
lo que explica la crisis al mismo tiempo
cuando el presidente macri llegada a la
presidencia en 2015 la deuda pública
representaba el 52 por ciento del
producto interno bruto cuando deje el
gobierno representaba ya el 91 por
ciento y esto hay que liquidarlo
sí es decir subió 34 por ciento en
cuatro años
los números ahí hay bastante discusión
sobre los números
porque en realidad
dos de cada tres dólares que tomo macri
fueron que se tomaron durante horas no
es matriz fueron para pagar deudas
antiguo exactamente entonces y te vuelvo
a decir no no la deuda no surge de la
nada la deuda surge de un déficit de un
déficit que fue heredado que no se atacó
hasta el final de la gestión macri
entonces las responsabilidades y están
ahí
te vuelvo a decir cuando tú miras el
tema de cómo varió el déficit fiscal el
comportamiento fiscal en el 2007
argentina tenía tres puntos del producto
de superávit en el 2002 en el 2015 tenía
cuatro puntos después de decir que no se
comieron en siete años siete puntos
entonces de siete puntos fiscales lo
cual significa en término el patrimonio
neto necesitas hacer uso de reservas
internacionales y qué es lo mismo que
endeudarse entonces de nuevo yo digo
para salir de macri cristina kirchner y
demás cuando uno mira la película
de la economía argentina los últimos 10
años en la mala gestión la verdad que
tenemos y tenemos problemas que venimos
arrastrando federico a este respecto
precisamente la cuestión es hoy en día
decíamos en un principio bueno hay tres
años ya de recesión hay una fuerte
inflación hoy en día es el segundo país
con mayor inflación de américa latina
después de venezuela se estima en más
del 40% del año pasado y seguramente
será superior este año el presidente
fernández dijo en su momento que tal y
como está la deuda actual con el fondo
monetario internacional al que se le
deben cuarenta y tantos mil millones de
los 57.000 que se habían acordado no se
puede pagar hoy en día de esta manera
recién ha hecho una gira por europa para
pedir se aligere las sobres tasas de
interés pero al final de cuentas parece
una ecuación difícil de cuadrar más allá
de la voluntad política de unos y otros
si mira como te decía argentina arrastra
hace diez años un proceso de
estanflación pero el estancamiento con
inflación exactamente ese estancamiento
con inflación
cuando miras los desequilibrios fiscales
externos la desocupación la pobreza a la
argentina en 50 años duplicó su
población y multiplicó por 50 la pobreza
hoy están con más del 42 por ciento de
gente pobre así es entonces que
argentina tiene un problema acá rastreó
hace mucho tiempo que en los últimos 10
años se agudizó de manera tremenda y eso
con que tiene que ver con que hay que
hacer cambios de fondos cambios
copernicanos secas una transformación en
la estructura productiva en la
estructura de funcionamiento de la
economía argentina es muy profundo eso
con que tiene que ver por lo que recién
hablamos de las cuentas fiscales de los
ingresos fiscales de la carga impositiva
tiene que ver con las regulaciones
laborales tiene que ver con el clima de
inversión entonces tiene que ver con
sincerar los precios del funcionamiento
de la economía y con tener un plan de
estabilización en serio entonces si no
se hace eso la argentina no va a salir
y la verdad que lo que uno ve es que
esas medidas de fondo y tomar el toro
por las astas como se dice se patea
siempre para adelante y nos quedamos
entretenidos en cosas menores dicho eso
el presenciamos el presidente fernández
alberto fernández reciente hizo una gira
por europa visitó portugal francia
estuvo también en españa de esos tres
gobiernos obtuvo el apoyo incluso el
propio papá parece que le ha dado su
apoyo fue que había gestionado la
entrevista con la directora del fondo
monetario internacional que está en
juego en esta negociación con el fondo
monetario internacional decíamos el
tiene que reembolsar el país tiene que
reembolsar le al fondo monetario
internacional casi 100 mil millones solo
de capital en tres años que lo que está
en juego las sobre tasas de interés si
ese se le deba a que la deuda que están
cuidados de tres es es un gesto yo creo
que es un poco menos son en tres años
son cuarenta algo así pero no importa lo
que digo es lo que tiene que hacer
argentina es de nuevo volverá a crecer
en primer lugar volverá a crecer y en
segundo lugar digo como
negociada a la deuda y lo que hay es lo
que hacen los países de rollover de la
deuda decir que la cosa rollover es se
re se generan nuevos nueva deuda para
afrontar los vencimientos que hay que si
no es que se cancela la deuda esto es
importante entenderlo porque conciencia
argentina tiene que enfrentar 50 mil o
sea no mire
en realidad argentina digamos la deuda
vencida se le paga con nueva deuda
porque mientras no aumente la
alimentaria la inflación de una cierta
no entiendo de cómo se lleve no por eso
digo no digamos el problema es cuando
uno no tiene acceso a los mercados de
crédito como es el caso argentina bueno
tiene que pagar con reservas su deuda y
eso es imposible pero si el gobierno si
la argentina empezará a crecer y el
gobierno tuviera acceso al mercado de
deuda ese no sería un problema el tema
es de nuevo volverá a crecer y hacer
sustentable las cuentas fiscales y las
cuentas externas nos queda poco tiempo
ya este respecto
según las proyecciones de crecimiento se
requerirán tres años por lo menos para
que se recupere el crecimiento que había
antes es decir vamos con una situación a
contrarreloj qué medidas precisas muy
brevemente por favor federico podría
implementarse rápidamente para controlar
la inflación relanzar la economía y
tratar en la medida de lo posible de
reducir el nivel de pobreza que parece
que va creciendo cada vez más de manera
vertical una pregunta fácil me estás
haciendo a braulio mira
como te decía hay que normalizar las
relaciones financieras internacionales
hay que cerrar el acuerdo con el fondo
monetario con el club de parís lo antes
posible está llevando demasiado tiempo
hay que tratar de poner en orden lo
monetario y lo fiscal y evitar que haya
emisión para financiar el déficit fiscal
y bueno y eso que forme parte de un
programa de estabilización un programa
estabilización para bajar la inflación
ningún país puede crecer con 40 ó con 50
por ciento de inflación no existe
entonces lo que hay que hacer es bajar
la inflación
bueno grandes desafíos esperan entonces
los presidentes alberto fernández
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a federico ignacio poli
economista consultor independiente quien
fuera director del banco interamericano
de desarrollo entre 2010 y 2020 para
argentinas edith y su presencia quien es
de escala gracias hídrico muchas gracias
a ustedes les damos otra cita la próxima
semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]